president Trump vowing to send as many
troops quote as necessary to stop
caravan of thousands marching toward the
United States if they reach the southern
border the president also blessing
Democrats for the problem you know how
the caravan started I think the
Democrats had something to do with it
and now they're saying I think we made a
big mistake that is an assault on our
country that's an assault
and in that Caravan you have some very
bad people you have some very bad people
and we can't let that happen to our
country Trump also not backing down
after saying terrorists and gang members
may be among the migrants
I spoke with border patrol this morning
and I spoke to him last evening and I
spoke to him the day before speak to him
all the time
and they say and you know this as well
as anybody over the course of the year
over the course of a number of years
they've intercepted many people from the
Middle East they've intercepted Isis
they've intercepted all sorts of people
they've intercepted wonderful people for
the Middle East and they've intercepted
bad ones they've intercepted wonderful
people from South America president
Trump continuing to ask answer questions
from the media I did want to play this
one more soundbite from just something
that's not gonna believe about what was
said about our military watch this if
you put military down there we know what
the god forbid is in this situation and
then how does it play how is that good
for anybody
if cuz you know you're not going to turn
or weigh thousands and thousands of
people even if people start getting shot
and what message does that send who wins
in that it did surprise me a little bit
that he would say that because our
military is not known for going after
innocent people they are there to try to
protect the border so anyway we'll start
with you Greg on this issue the caravan
they're not stopping
he's not very bright as that Cuomo fella
well that was not a nice thing to say it
wasn't it wasn't a nice thing to say no
it wasn't I just wonder about the media
because they tend not to ask the very
specific questions like how did the
caravan start who called it a caravan
how is the event being managed to or the
people managing it they always keep
saying that the caravan is blooming like
it's some kind of natural event but it's
actually it without it's spontaneous but
no it's actually quite organized it's
organized by actually Mexican advocacy
groups and then when you get to the
sizable group of people in which you
can't tell who's in the group and who is
it which is why you need a process
because it could be ten
there could be terrorists and obviously
there could not be terrorists but who's
gonna know so the media then takes the
narrative and they twist it so after
helping the onslaught multiply right
they accused Trump of seizing it seizing
it as an issue when beforehand it was
the media in the adverts advocacy groups
who had seized on this spectacle to
begin with to create an ugly political
issue and then they go
but look what Trump is doing there bunch
of hypocrites and you know what's even
sadder a vanetti
is telling the Democrats to grow a spine
when Michael Alvin Eddy becomes your
voice of reason for your party you're in
trouble the others talking about that in
terms of the media coverage on some
media critics saying that that the media
should not take president Trump's words
and use them so that onslaught was too
strong that they are saying that maybe
there's some softer language that should
be used because they're doing his
bidding it's like the mob controversy so
call it a caravan it's a parade that's
what they're probably going to say to
Greg's point about the media they've
reported breathlessly about how many
scoops of ice cream this president has
and they're not even curious about how
this Caravan is happening right now I
think the only people that have sent
reporters down to embed in the caravan
Fox News we have Sarah Carter down there
William la jeunesse William la jeunesse
as well the Washington Post has someone
down there and Judicial Watch even has
someone down there there's just not a
lot of interest in the mainstream media
so when Trump says something about the
caravan there's no way for them to
fact-check it they're going to assume
that the president is saying incorrect
things and some of the reporting coming
out of there very interesting 80% of
those people in the migrant Caravan are
males under the age of 35 and they're
not fleeing violence these are economic
refugees and you know what they told The
Washington Post when they get there and
start making money in America
they're gonna wire the money back to El
Salvador some of these people are gang
affiliated a lot of these people also
have been previously deported and that's
been confirmed so if they're really that
upset about the conditions in their
country instead of marching up north to
America March against your own corrupt
government that would solve a lot of
problems in my opinion and then here
one of course we're two weeks away from
the midterms two weeks today so somebody
like a Joe Donnelly and a Claire
McCaskill to red state Democrats that
are running for re-election they know
that for the next 13 days if that the
Republican candidates are going to be
using this issue and it's not good for
them in their campaigns no because
anytime you use fear-mongering I think
it really pushes a button and I think
the president and the Republicans right
now absent a message for the midterms
have decided this is the button to push
I read today we're Stephen King the
horror film our book writer said you
know that the Republican campaign theme
here is be afraid don't be brave be
afraid and therefore even today the
president who suggested Oh guess what
there could be Middle Eastern terrorists
among these people they're all gang
members today he said well we don't have
proof but they could be couldn't be
that's a point that's all he does he
just pushes he just pushes the fear
button when he doesn't have anything
else to say and to me what's incredible
is my Republican friends buy this stale
bread of hatred because it is so so the
president even goes farther he says I'm
a nationalist last night you know what
these globalist want to come in here and
take over Nashua swear we've heard that
from white nationalists Steve ban and
that whole long race is so horrible so
intentionally divisive oh these brown
words are divisive to call yourself your
sons are Republicans publicans racist no
I'm calling this action by this
president given the divisive nature of
it just do nothing no because remember
we've had things like the Mariel
boatlift if you think back tonight was a
very good thing right but guess what how
did America reacting I think about how
we reacted in terms of we are even
interest even if you think about the
Jewish Exodus you think about Irish
people coming to this country as a
result of famine you compare an epidemic
there were people on the far right who
react oh stop them stop those Jews I'm
coming in here why is that the way that
you and Emily do you think that that is
it that this is comparable no and I also
want I want to point out two things here
number one that this
humanitarian crisis pre-existed this
caravan and to me the mixed messaging
and the hypocrisy is coming from the
left who are ignoring the fact that
sixteen journalists were killed this
year alone in Mexico and all of the
attention is on Khashoggi or the 600
megan's that migrants that were found
dead in Texas because of the chokehold
the cartels have on not only those
governments south of us but also those
people including the fact that an entire
Police Office was arrested for
corruption in Jalisco so this the border
security is a small portion of the
absolute crisis that is going down south
and the humanitarian crisis aspect of it
it's because of the poorest border and
the lack of the laws that we have to
keep strong and then secondly about that
about the military and about those
military comments viewers need to
understand that the National Guard comes
under state authority obviously with
federal funds the president can
federalize them active duty military the
the exception to the Posse Comitatus Act
is the fact that if active duty military
is in a support not in law enforcement
role then that's how that is legal so
that the completing of the issues and
the hyperbole from the left are saying
that they're going to start shooting
people is absolutely offensive and
totally incredibly I just wanted to pick
up on something you said yeah we
disagree obviously I feel so
passionately about this I just think
this is this is lowball politics but
something you said so important this is
a humanitarian crisis predates this and
people should think of it in those terms
because I think that conservatives
historically have been empathetic
compassionate people not like what this
president is doing I got to address some
of the things that you just said Sarah
Carter one of your colleagues here at
Fox News went down there actually you're
not there she's down there she's a
colleague spoke to Guatemalan
intelligence and interviewed people in
the caravan and has confirmed that
there's ms-13 affiliated gang members
among the care of it if you're gonna sit
there and call your colleague a liar
while you're sitting on your tush in a
nice air-conditioned studio in Manhattan
I really think that's unbecoming second
of all you have not said what regime
hoodie what are you gonna do about the
caravan Juan Oh
no plan is there anything about it are
you can you add anything to what to do
with this
sure 7000 you're going to strong north
do I think that it's very clear given
that Republicans control the White House
why don't they fix the immigration
system that's so badly because of
Democrat there we go the Feinstein
ministration attracts these people is
local politics and you are message for
president from Paula today he said he
has no proof you may be your check
further my election integrity you don't
want to protect the Integrity's were
Russians comes across oddly build the
wall and so these people are coming with
guns they're hordes coming now they're
going to take over America nobody's
taking over anything according to one's
logic Mexico is also racist because
they're trying to limit the immigration
as well they're sending troops to their
border
so clearly the Mexicans are rapists who
want everybody's racism to race me oh
you're filth is nothing but race I think
you have a difficulty acknowledging
where there's racial injustice and where
someone is using a racial pitch to stir
his base in order to try to enter the
borders Juan I'm not racist